[Music]
exactly
one year ago my grandpa and his
girlfriend
were on the back of a moped in vietnam
you heard that right my 82 year old
grandpa
and his 79 year old girlfriend were
zipping down the busy streets of ho chi
minh city
as part of a month-long trip through
southeast asia
now for those of you curious my
grandpa's dating life
is relatively new my grandma passed away
a number of years ago after a 56 year
long marriage to my grandpa
we were all quite worried about him and
so
it came as quite a surprise to learn
that my grandpa
had a girlfriend he and his girlfriend
barb
have spent the past three years golfing
exercising traveling just enjoying life
every year my grandpa and i have a
tradition of going out to lunch
just the two of us and every year he
tells me
this is the happiest year of his life
my grandpa is my inspiration for how i
want to live
at 82 at 62
and right now at 28.
he's also my inspiration for starting a
business
in the aging space to expand the ways
that
business and society think about growing
older
this is a talk about reimagining aging
and why you should build products and
services for people
over 65 and i'll do that by first
explaining why aging is not what you
think it is
where businesses are falling short and
what you
can do about it this
concept of a long life is relatively new
for the vast majority of human history
life expectancy
was under 40. consider this
when the social security act of 1935 was
passed
giving financial benefits to retirees
life expectancy
was 61. now it is 79
and yet when the norm is still to retire
at 60 or 65
retirement can be 20 sometimes
30 years long
30 years that's a long
time some people
have a misconception that long life
comes at a trade-off
with quality of life but for many that's
simply not the case
in a cohort of 80 to 85 year olds a
study found
three quarters had no physical health
limitations
and i have more good news for you older
people are generally happier
you might think that you're having a
great time here at stanford
but the chances are your happiness will
peak in your 60s
and 70s and lastly this concept of a
retirement
that we work for 40 continuous years and
one day just stop forever
is changing people over 60 are
entering the workforce in greater
numbers than any other demographic
and that's a reflection of both their
desire and ability
to stay working and to stay engaged
now if i painted this very rosy picture
of what aging can look like
i'd like to tell you that businesses are
falling short
if i were to ask you to build a product
for an 82 year old what would you think
of
maybe you would think of a medication
organizer
maybe you would think of redesigning the
walker
and it's true some 82 year olds
certainly need these things
but not my grandpa my grandpa
wants a moped my grandpa
shops at nike and yet when he comes home
and turns on the tv
here are the ads that he sees
part of the problem is that businesses
view older people
as this monolithic demographic that the
day you turn 65
you're now the same as everybody else
with the same wants
and the same needs but the truth
is that there is no universal experience
of growing older
everyone walks a unique path
and that's why building for people over
65
is the biggest overlooked business
opportunity
to put some numbers behind that every
single day
10 000 people turn 65
older adults control over three quarters
of wealth in the u.s
and over half of consumer spending
and yet only 10 percent of marketing
dollars go towards them
and older people hate the way that
they're marketed to
my grandpa needs unique products and
services designed for this very specific
phase of life that he is in
there are so many opportunities to
capture both the minds
and the wallets of older adults and help
us all
reimagine what the last 30 years of our
lives
can look like if i piqued your interest
in the aging space
i want to highlight three areas of
opportunity where we need more focus
the first is affording retirement
how do we finance a 100 year long life
span
it requires a complete reimagination of
the ways that we invest
save and pay for the things like health
care
41 percent of americans do not think
that they will be able to retire
comfortably
and existing government programs like
social security and medicare
are just not enough as an example
under medicare you're still required to
pay for 20
of the cost of your care which for many
is unaffordable we need people to create
products that create financial security
over the course of one's immense
lifespan
the second area of opportunity is
helping people age in place
ninety percent of people want to age in
their own homes
and that's particularly true during this
pandemic
but there are barriers think of your own
home
think of those sharp corners in your
kitchen
the slick surfaces in your bathroom
those hard to turn doorknobs
there's an entire industry of home
renovators
who will come into your house make it
safer
more accessible for older bodies
aging in place is not just about the
physical safety of our homes
it's about finding social connection in
our community
caring for our family caregivers and
bringing
healthcare out of the hospital and into
the home
lastly and most importantly the biggest
area of opportunity
is helping people find purpose
think of all the things that happen in
the first 30 years of your life
you learn how to walk you make your
first friend
you go to school graduate college
come here to stanford what happens in
the last
30 years of your life what are you doing
and who are you doing it with
this is where we need strong consumer
brands that evoke emotion
and inspire
i hope that we will all be impacted by
aging
we will age our loved ones will age
our customers will age
that is my wish for all of you
so if you're an entrepreneur build your
business
in the aging space if you're working at
a company
how might you expand your target market
and if there's an aging loved one in
your life
talk to them ask them what their hopes
and dreams are for this next chapter
there are so many opportunities to
create impact
in the aging space and help us all
re-imagine what the last 30 years of our
lives
can look like